hey everyone it's michaelos from order
flows.com and this is the orderflows
market analysis for Wednesday June 14
2017 now the big thing on the economic
calendar was the fomc FC followed their
script and raised the FED funds rate one
notch to
1.25% and it's still low um you know
you're still talking you know even
though it rais a quarter we're still at
one and a quarter that's still uh pretty
pretty darn low now you know the
economic data that came out earlier
before the C doesn't really help out the
FED um you know it doesn't really point
to higher rates this year we had CPI
actually fell and retail sales were
unusually weak now you know problem I
have with these retail sales is you know
again I'm not an economist I don't claim
to be and you know I might be totally
totally wrong in this but you know I
really wonder how much uh online sales
are actually recorded in this retail
sales number um you know my sister works
in the retail industry and you know she
you know Macy's just closed a bunch of
stores this year um you know every year
they're closing about 100 stores and
really these bricks and motar stores are
going under and I I do while I do think
you know that makes retail sales look
weak really there's a lot of um a lot of
sales going out online um you know I
mean a lot of you know small sellers
individual sellers selling things that
you know I I don't think that's really
captured in in retail sales I know
people are spending um but uh
yeah again I when I when I see numbers
like you know retail sales come out weak
and usually weak in this case down
3% you know I I really temper it with uh
you know really what's what's going on I
know a lot of guys that run these stores
on Shopify and um all these other
platforms and and they're making money
hand over fist so um again you know I I
really I'm not sure how how really weak
retail sales really are but anyway you
know again I I think their way of
counting in retail sales um doesn't
really accurately reflect what's going
on in the market but anyway that's just
my own um my own U what you call it my
own analysis again I'm no um Harvard
educated say Harvard but uh Princeton or
Yale educated Economist you know I'm
just a normal person
Now Stocks were mixed though um you know
with the fomc uh Dow did hit a new
record 21374 for um you know the other
indices were you know a little bit lower
S&P I think were lower um crude again Mo
had a big move today where there was
another draw in the weekly inventories
and we're down about a buck 75 and uh we
closed somewhere near about 4475 or
$45 um and again that's not going to
help the fomc meet its inflation goal um
so anyway uh let's jump into it uh brief
the disclaimer before I get started this
presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a Futures Contract or make any the
type of investment decision Futures
training contains substantial risk and
is not for every investor an investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's Financial Security or
lifestyle only risk Capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk Capital should consider
trading pass performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
again the tools you use in my
presentations are the orderflows trader
software which is the volume footprint
chart and the delta scalper which is a
tool that I created to help um analyze
the Delta you know again it's it's not a
trading indicator in the P sense rather
what it does is it reads the the Delta
and the price action and tells me you
know if if it looks like the market is
transitioning from a supply driven
Market to a demand driven Market or from
a demand driven Market to a supply
driven Market again this is normal
analysis you could just do um without
using the Delta scalper and if you just
have a volume footprint chart you can do
it yourself as long as you have Delta on
your chart and you know it's a tool to
help help you um find more trading
opportunities so anyway um you know that
said we'll we'll jump into it first uh
Market we'll talk about today is uh talk
about bonds um you there there really
wasn't that many great trading
opportunities in the bonds but um you
know Bonds were on a tear this morning a
big tear and uh you know it all started
just around 7:30 very quiet morning
before coming into 7:30
and then the number came out and the
market just took off
here so you know coming into the 7:30
time we had uh very quiet overnight
session um
15329 was the low you know and by 6 in
the you know I mean just before 6 you
know we at our high of 15410 so a very
tight range made a new high around just
after 6:00 we got up to uh
and you know just sort of went sideways
and the number came out and we had a
nice big rally now again I'm not saying
I'd be trading around this number no I
wouldn't you know even though there
there's some bullish things in here very
tight range I'm not looking to take a
position right ahead of of a number I
mean come on you had uh retail sales you
had CPI coming out and for anyone to say
come out and said yeah you should have
bought right here you know at 729 in 50
seconds I think is uh pulling your chain
but any anyway you know the market you
know people do trade the numbers and you
know some people are quite successful at
it but again I'm not an economist I
don't try to be and you know I I rather
just let the market speak to me so
anyway number came out 7:30 we we went
we rallied we made new highs um
basically a half a point um and just
kept going higher higher higher all
morning till about 10:00
now you know as this Market started to
slow down around you know 750 745 750
time um we started making new highs
again and you know when you're making
these highs you're getting the type of
highs you like like to see you like to
see new highs on buying and balance on
strong positive Deltas 1,00 1500 1,000
25,000 you even got a stack buying in
Balance this one is a little it weakened
out a little bit here um you know I just
had a small Delta of uh 187 but you know
okay it it's not the end of the world
it's still positive Delta then it comes
right back with a strong Delta
638 um 1,000 on this red bar now this is
where things got a little bit
interesting I I thought um you know
maybe this move was starting to out you
know you got negative Delta negative
Delta here in these two bars 143 830
then it comes back up here
1,600 and then here you get this bar
with the ratio with the Divergence which
for me is is an almost a automatic trade
and it's ratio bounds low next bar is
lower as well so it looks nice but
unfortunately we just went lower by two
more ticks and then you got a bullish
ratio here again this bar point of
control near the bottom and you know
what was interesting on this little move
off this high is you're seeing some
strong numbers come in here you're
seeing 4,000 1500 2 3,000 even here in
the next bar another 2,000 so in this
area here around 12 um you're seeing
some supportive buying com in 4,000
3,000 this is already um 8,000 in this
bar another you know 2 and a half th000
it's 10,000 coming in you know being
traded here at at 12 here you've got you
know 3,000 in this bar another 1,500 in
this bar so I know there's buyers here
at 11 at 12 you know then I get a small
print here 57 Lots I get a bullish ratio
it's telling me there's price rejection
down here that in the sense
that you know people aren't interested
in in selling anymore because there's
probably still more buyers down here in
what happens the market snaps back you
seeing buying imbalances although you
expect to see buying imbalances um
towards the bottom here like this 160
against 1028 3 against 1099 57 against
uh 2972 cuz on a green bar right the
place that you're going to have the
smallest volume on the bids side is
right here so you often have an
imbalance here just as on this on a red
bar you'll often get it you know on on
this spot right here like where the 737
is because it's 737 against 102 67
against 826 like that um 108 against 639
these are spots where imbalances
generally um occur more you know
regularly but anyway um you know they're
still solid you know th000 th000 th000
2,000 here and we're going higher
um you hit this one bar here negative
Delta Okay negative Delta fine but you
know again just cuz you have one bar
with negative Delta doesn't mean this
moves over you got a Divergence it comes
right back up makes a new high again
it's a failed Divergence so if you're
just trading divergences by themselves
be careful because you know they fail
more just about as often as they succeed
um you know that's why I like taking
them with ratios you at least it gives
me a little bit better understanding
that the market can sell off because
with the ratio I believe in price
rejection or price um
support price defense rather and you
know it did come off I mean it came off
a few ticks nothing special um I'm not
claiming this as some great Victory but
um but anyway you know we went higher
now it's getting up to 12:00 1:00 is the
announcement again you know on a Fed day
I'm not really interested in taking any
signal like here you got the Delta
scalper at 12:30 well I know that in the
last you know hour before the
announcement the Market's going to quiet
down so you'll be lucky if you get one
or two bars before the rate announcement
and you get one bar then the rate
announcement comes out thins out a lot
very thin volume here um we hit this
high again that we had hit earlier first
time 83 second time 207 but again it's
right on the rate announcement um you're
not going to be trading it and you just
go sideways for a bit for about uh 30
minutes you start selling off
um you know to me there's not really
much to be
interested in trading at this point you
know again it's it's one rate rate
announcements at
1:00 2 o'clock is you know the
unofficial Bond close in the sense of
you know that's when cash dealers close
their books for the day um and you know
it just wait for the next day when
things are settled down and people are
have time to assess the market now you
know there are some ratios here like you
know this one this one you two in a row
here then um you start seeing some here
one two again again um it's but again
it's 2:25 in the afternoon you know I I
do like this little move up but again
you know I mean I like this imbalance
here I see how the market is coming down
is reading some support but again I'm
not looking at trade bonds at 225 in the
afternoon um and we are a little bit
higher higher from that low but we're
lower from the close right now in the
evening session now the five years were
kind of similar but you know five years
gave you a little bit better uh trading
opportunities in in the sense of uh
Delta scalper and and um Divergence in
ratios
so you know early uh I say early but
8:43 you had this first um Delta scaler
give you a signal it didn't work out it
came right back honestly when it got
down to this point I was watch I
remember looking at this level at uh
195 thinking you know if we get below
there some selling could come in and
push this Market lower and I was looking
for a move lower down to about 17 only
got down to what is that 18 and a
quarter um but there was some decent
volume down here you see 1,800 5,000 um
1,700 in this bar another 2900 in this
bar so that's about close to 4,000 there
and obviously 1 14400 and then the
market came right back Delta scalper
given a buy so this Delta scalper here
this this signal failed um you know you
would have taken a loss and the next one
came back and give you a nice trade you
rallied up up up up making new highs
again you're making highs on solid solid
Delta uh here 7,000 8,000 13,000 these
are strong numbers and they're strong in
the sense that they're closing almost on
your max Delta number
6,854 that's your max Delta 7445 Max
Delta 7446 8696 Max Delta is
8945 13,400 is 14,000 now then you get
up here and it's all changed you had
positive Delta of
4,983 and what happens it changes a lot
of selling comes in up here this is 10:
in the morning and you all a sudden you
end up with a negative Delta 8519 your
Min Delta is
8638 so you know the bar
had a big shift you know from you know
that's a move of plus 5,000 to - 8,000
and you got a ratio and a Divergence
which I talk about till I'm blew in the
face and you got a nice come selloff so
you know this is one of those days where
you know the first trade you know is a
losing trade second trade's a decent
winner third trade's a decent winner so
again you know if you if you give up
after the first trade you let it get to
you say ah you know this day sucks I'm
not going to trade you know I should
have had a winner there it turned on me
became a
loser and then you missed you know then
you missed the next
trade and then you kick yourself because
you know what's worse than having a
loser is is not taking a trade that's a
winner um you know it affects you just
as much as a loser and then you know
1:00 comes out and know very thin volume
you can just see it here you get some
signals Delta scop weget I'm not looking
to trade at that time um you know it
does slow down a
bit about
130ish and then we just go sideways for
the most part we do come down into this
sort of a swing low no ratio down there
and you know right now in the evening
session we're just a little bit
lower now we'll look at snps really
quick 10 range find you
here snps you know I I thought the day
would be a little bit more quiet in
early on honestly um it wasn't it sold
off in the
morning where was I here so anyway um
coming back to around the 7ish morning
time um yeah we had hit our high up here
at
8:30 and you know prior you know when we
hit that high 43 and a quarter was the
high 35 was the low so you're talking
about 8o range and then you know opening
prices 38 and A4 and then you know
around 8:30 we started started rotating
around it for the next half hour I
really thought we'd spend more time just
sort of hanging around it but some
selling came in you could just see it in
the Deltas mostly negative
Deltas um you know there wasn't any
reason to be buying it down here um you
know people you know I talk a lot about
buying on lows or selling on Highs but
again you know that's not what I do per
se rather I let the market tell me to if
if I should be buying near the lows or
selling near the highs and right now
it's not telling me anything it's not
telling me to get long and you know we
just sort of hover around here now going
going sideways until
1:00 from you know this is from you know
what time on this slow 10:00 until until
1:00 so that's 2 hours then the number
comes out again you know it give it some
time you know we got an announcement
coming out then I believe you had a
press conference later and you know let
the market settle down you know if you
bought this low the swing low
here with the Delta scalper you know it
went up up yeah but then you know
selling came in you got a stacked
inbalance here and the market came in
and took you out but
then you know later you had a nice
buying opportunity down here what do you
got you got a ratio 68 you got a
Divergence and you know the market did
pop up a little bit then you gets up
here to a bearish ratio and then just
starts going sideways on you and then
comes down here and takes you out again
and then you know so you know imagine
you know think your way through it here
now this again you have this um swing
high up here again I'm not looking to
take any trade you know right around the
1:00 to 115 even 130 is pushing it here
124 but still um you know I I do think
around this time the market has kind of
quieted down it's taking a few minutes
taking more than you know 30 seconds to
form a bar here you know this bar took
10 minutes so to me the market is quiet
down a bit um you know things do pick up
again later but you know 14 49 you know
to me this is a go trade you know this
one is borderline with if I would have
taken I probably would have bit um this
one I definitely would have bit um and
you know so the second time you know two
trades didn't work out for me there um
then what do you get here you got your
new low 2425 and 3/4 Divergence no ratio
next bar you got the ratio and you got
the Delta scalper giving you a Buy
Signal this is you know 2 222 in the
morning uh in the afternoon and
and now it's go time you know so put out
the losing trades get them out of your
mind you know you're getting long here
2430 and what do you do you know it
rallies all the way up to 35 even goes
higher you I like on 10 range I like to
shoot for about five ticks and you know
you get it so you know you have your
your two losing trades you could beat
yourself up over but again you know
don't sit there and say ah you know I
shouldn't be trading today and just give
up you know if if you're going to do
that might as well just cut down your
size to the minimum one lot and keep
keep trading and try and get yourself
back on side again at least mentally you
know end the day with the winning trade
whether it's a winning trade for one
tick on a one lot or you know uh five
ticks or five points on um you know on
five Lots you know at least try to end
the day feeling good about yourself you
know I mean people at you know different
ways of handling losing days not saying
know this this could have been a losing
day but still you know I I know people
that really beat themselves up over
having a losing day like oh you know
they they take it personally like like
for whatever reason they don't know what
they're doing um there was a guy on the
Board of Trade you know after he have a
losing day he'd go out and buy himself
something nice you know spend a grand a
couple Grand on on something just
because he knows that you know even
though he has a losing day he still has
money you know that that he could still
afford you know things in life and you
know me trading is the mental game of
trading is very important
and right now you know we are a little
bit lower you know here in the overnight
session can you this three in a row but
um you then you get hit this Divergence
but again it's the evening session right
off the open reopen you got three in a
row I'm not a big fan of of trading you
know signals right based on the opening
but anyway um you know right now trading
2430 we'll see where it ends up uh in
the morning
time
now what else I want to talk about uh
crude oil I think crude oil again you
know crude oil was down again today um
you know where are we trading right now
4464 but you know there was still you
know you had the the inventory numbers
come out at 9:30 um but even before that
I believe it was something interesting
worth talking about
um yeah this High I remember talking
about this high in the room you
had you're coming up here you got 663
positive Delta you got a stack buying
inbalance that's nice tells me you know
this Market can potentially go higher
then what happens you start coming up
here 96 positive Delta 105 and a red bar
and then boom minus 524 Delta you know
this this the way it changes in this bar
is very telling that hey you know what
we've changed we've gone from a demand
driven Market to a supply driven market
demand you know buying buy and buying um
positive Delta positive Delta then weak
positive Delta on your high weak
positive I was kind of I'll say weak
positive Delta but you know it's only
100 it was positive 400 at one point
ended up at just 100 so it gave it all
back and then big selling came in here
524 if you're not convinced yet say ah
you know I'm not convinced then you get
this bar very neutral Delta 11 you know
it's the difference of one trade two
trades maybe and then bam another big
selling bar with a lot of selling coming
minus Delta 7 706 at this point you
should say you know what sellers have
taken over already and over the next few
bars you go lower then you just sort of
hang around sideways until the inventory
numbers come out um volume thins out you
can just see it's all over the place
here um you do pound into some new
lows
and you know later you know it's still
this this is still 9:31 here so you know
you had this big move from again you
know I I see people talking about you
know trading this you know trading crude
around these uh inventory numbers like
like it's easy to do you know they trade
it in Sim or whatever I guess but you
know they don't trade it with real money
but think about it for a second here
929 you know now come you know inventory
comes out 9:30 you know maybe my clock's
a little off but your trading at your
high
4649 okay and then what happens number
inventory number comes comes out 4649
right that's your high and 9:30 and 15
seconds you're trading 4572 so you had a
75 C move from your high to new lows
actually you went lower um you know down
to 4566 so um you know 80 cent move so
you know these people are say oh yeah
you know you just trade it you take your
position up here right at the high get
short yeah then you know 15 seconds
later you're 75 cents in the money
that's all um you know I mean
you try and do that with real money and
when it goes 75 cents against you uh
tell me how great a Trader you are but
anyway um
940 you know has the market got his
footing back it's still moving pretty
quick and you know there's still a lot
of selling going on it's put in some you
know each bar has got decent volume it's
about one bar is about 30
seconds and you know it's tra about
2,000 Lots per bar a lot of selling
coming in here still 9941 you know 940
you got four bars 9:41 you got about
five or six bars so the market still
hasn't slowed down
yet um you know finally it starts to
slow down around um
10:00 and this time we're trading much
lower trading 44 you know for whoops
what's going on here um
4477 and you know you get down towards
your low you have a Delta scalper giving
you this buy here just before 10:00 you
know it's a green bar yeah do I kind of
like it yeah I do but you know it
doesn't work out it fails um then you
hit this low here ratio no d uh sorry a
Divergence no ratio it's still a black
number um you Market pops up a little
bit but then selling comes right back in
again there's no reason to be buying off
off this low yet
um you got
this you know to me this is what a stop
um stop induced selling IM balance looks
like here with all these zeros then you
get to pull back um into those
areas and
you know again is there any reason be
buying down here yet no not not really
um yeah even here is there a reason
other than the Delta scalper well I mean
you are starting to string together some
positive Deltas which is nice I mean if
you are going to Rally off the low
you're going to need to string together
some positive Deltas um you know selling
does come in once in a while on some of
these bars you can see - 360 - 430
doesn't necessarily mean it's over um
again you know down here again you get
the Delta scalper coming back in almost
at the same level but a little bit
higher I believe but at this point the
market is just going sideways on you
again you know are you going to take it
12:00 you could take it but you know
when you start getting around 1:00 be
careful if you're still in that position
in this case the market just sort of
hung around and did nothing for the next
15 minutes and then um it started
picking up again but for the most part
after that you know this area
4470 um you know know
4465 you know that's about where we we
spent you know where we where we closed
you know here we closed around 4470 I
think um right now we're just you know
went lower in the evening s came back up
we're just right around uh
4465 so I mean There Was You Know crude
oil was was I'll say a difficult Market
but it was a market where there's a lot
of of stuff on the table um that's going
to affect your your trading decisions um
I said you got inventory numbers you got
fomc so there's just a bunch uh you know
you had a full plate to to deal with now
soybeans soybeans are interesting um you
know reopen a830 here came up to this
high this is not a this is a ratio but
it's not a Divergence it's you know it's
a signal tell me there spy some trap
Traders up in here do we come off a
little bit yeah we come off about a
penny rally back
up got a new high with a Divergence no
ratio but but you get the ratio on the
next bar plus a stack selling IM balance
which is good you know I said I always
talk about you know if you can't get the
ratio in the bar with the Divergence
look to the next bar for the ratio and
you get it here plus you get a stack
sellum balance telling you hey get short
and you know the market sells off about
uh 3 cents and just sort of go sideways
a little bit later you get another Delta
scalper cell here and we sell off from
you know the 935 A2 area down into um
931 area um before closing and go
sideways in the evening session now it's
interesting in the evening session you
have this low here at the 9:30 with some
very solid volume
819 again I'll be very interested to see
if we test that again tonight if I mean
I'm sure the volume is still
there
now uh Euro currency think you I okay
the data on the CME website hasn't come
out about the the open interest for the
day if it's I I do believe it'll switch
you know this is what time is it now
it's 8 quarter after 8 tonight
and you know this is the CME website and
they have you know what I'm watching is
it's on Monday the uh 19th is the
contract expiration for the the June and
the volume is still in the well this is
for Tuesday right right here Tuesday
they don't have the Wednesday final yet
um but I I just know by looking at my
charts late in the day that the volume
is thinning out in the June already but
I think you know by later when they
update this I I think you'll see this
the change big negative here um for the
June in the open interest and a big
positive and you'll see the open
interest is taken over in the uh in the
subcontract um that's how I know to you
know get out of the or stop I say get
out but rather stop trading the June
contract
and so let me just pull up the Drew I
can just see by looking at the the
volume how how sort of how thin it is
you know these these numbers you know
you don't get really many bars with 100
contracts in it when normally you
would but anyway there there was still
some interesting things here again you
know 1:00 Market just went
Bonkers
um
we go
back go back to around 7 o'clock I like
starting around you know 720 is the old
floor open but um again you know just
bear in mind that you had the 7:30 you
had a number come out
um but anyway it sort of slowed down I
thought it slowed down about 5 minutes
after this this number came out and you
get your high here no ratio no
Divergence um next bar you got a ratio
you do have the delta scalper come out
next bar was lower but
um you hit this one bar here with the
point of control right on the bottom
here and a bullish ratio so to me this
setup in this bar is very bullish as
well and then the market rally I I
didn't expect it to come on rally all
the way up to new Highs but as far as
getting out of the short position when I
see a bar like this it's telling me hey
you know what there's some support down
here um be be uh you know if you're in a
position get out or you know maybe take
something you know some ticks out of the
trade and then you see so you're you're
hanging around here right you got
negative Delta negative Delta Even This
Bar negative Delta small negative Delta
then this part positive positive
positive you're going into the highs on
some decent positive Deltas you know 253
300 stacked buying and balance um do you
make new highs yeah you do and then you
just sort of go sideways come around
Circle back up you get some selling come
in and then positive Deltas again um you
know a bunch of scattered buying
imbalances in here on the way
up
um 808 you had
this ratio with the Divergence now yeah
it's a ratio bounds low but just looking
at these numbers to me it's kind of
small you know that's why I I I say you
know it's you know be careful um you
know I like to look at numbers I'm
always hesitant when they're they're
sort of smallish numbers 8 5 3 6 1 um
you know for a ratio bonds low I'd be
looking I'd like to see you know better
numbers than that up here you get a
Divergence no ratio ratio in the next
bar but again it's still relatively
small volume you know the market does um
sell off a little bit rallies back up
within two ticks of that
high and then sells
off um here you get the Delta scalper
giving a sell and just sort of go
sideways on you makes a new high failed
Divergence there
um nothing really up in there and then
you know it's and then just started
slowing down between you know 9:30 to
10:00 which is around you know 10:30
this is around the European close
time Del the scalper gave a sell here
and he just came right back on you
um 12 o'l now again you know it's
12:00 and you've
got you got an
fomc coming out in an hour do you want
to be taking any trades you know 12:00
you probably could um unfortunately if
you took this it just came right back on
you now again you know the telling thing
that there was some that this move
wasn't going to go any higher is this
bar here you got some decent volume up
here you got this buying in Balance
you've got 125 142 so I know there's
some volume towards the top of this bar
the sellers came in up here
to hold support this I'll say support
this when you say when I say the word
support you you think of something you
know buying but you know defend is
probably a better level better word and
then you can see just selling you know
the buying just dropped dried up okay
you know went bid here 142 even um and
then you know once these people were
buying it trying to get it higher
realized it couldn't go higher it's like
you know they just put their hands back
in their pocket and the market just fell
over um you can see you know what little
volume is traded on the bid
here hardly any buying and here on the
way down and then the market just you
know comes off another 10 ticks now you
come up here at 1257 again I'm not going
to take any trades right ahead of that
rate announcement you can see it's all
13:00 and you know 10 seconds 9
seconds 11 seconds 14 seconds um it's
pointless to talk about you know what's
going on in the Overflow because it's
just so
thin you know Market settles down um you
know when does the market settle down
it's it's hard to say um you know we you
do have some big volume support in here
you got a thousand traded on the bid
here at
47 you know so you know whenever I see
big volume like that in most markets I'd
be interested sometimes though in the
currencies I'm a bit hesitant because it
could be against the cash position you
don't know um but still you got a nice
stack selling and balance and you got a
ratio on the next bar I like stacked
selling and balances with bearish ratios
in the next bar or the opposite would be
a stack buying IM balance with a bullish
ratio um I find this a find this to be a
higher percentage trade than just a
stacked imbalance on itself and you'll
notice how where did this bar come up to
it came right up to the point of control
here where you had the Thousand so you
know there's got through there you know
if if you've ever traded the market and
there's a real legitimate bid there that
you're selling into whether it's an
iceberg or a solid bid where showing the
whole thing um when you get through it
you often snap back up to that level and
you might see still see some selling
come back in there now again I'm not
saying it's only 22 it's not much but
you know it's still a level that you
know people were watching you know
everyone was trying to get it past this
level and they did and it bounced back
up right up to that level selling came
back in again and it sold off quite uh
quite nicely very quick this is um no
it's the time it's 134 and 22 seconds
and you know 10 seconds later at 32
seconds um you know we're trading down
from 47 down to uh you know basically
37 and we know we still just keep
dropping dropping dropping um yeah you
do get the Del the cper giving you a buy
here but again you know this Market is
moving very very fast now not
necessarily a lot of
volume Delta Scupper but it's on a red
candle here so again I'm not really
interested in taking it Market's still
moving very fast you know one bar is
taking you know in some cases less than
a second to form um that's so there's
still volatility in this
market you there's there's nobody
putting a gun to your head the training
saying you got to trade during fast
market conditions um you know if the
Market's just going nutso on you you
know just wait for it to settle down you
know wait wait for it to wait for the
market to tell you
something know this was interesting you
had to stack buying and balance on the
red candle normally you'd get stack
buying and balances on green candles but
in this case it's a red candle so you
know it's not big in balances eight it's
one against eight three against 13 four
against 18 um but you but selling came
in late and pushed the market lower to
me that's that's a bearish signal um
again I'm not looking for this to be
selling off from uh you know 11 125 all
the way down to you know 11175 you know
for me this would be a short-term
scalping trade here get you know you
know get you know 5 10 ticks out of
it um but anyway then we hit our low
about
226 got a Divergence no ratio no ratio
in the next bar um again you start going
up you can just see the volume is I I
think
has drained out of the I say drained out
but it's gotten much lesser in the June
contract I think I got sep sep chart up
here sep footprint chart let me see yeah
you just compare the volumes and and see
for
yourself h on a
sec um bear with me
here okay here's the sub contract so
this is uh
September and surprisingly it's still
the volume is still in the June um this
is right
now you can see slightly more volume
still in the June contract and in the se
but again you know again
it's it's uh one of those things you
know which contract should you be
trading right now during the roll again
you know we haven't come out they have
not come out with this
uh the updated they haven't updated the
website with the uh the change but you
know I really it's coming Thursday and I
said you know the contract expires on
uh whoops here
calendar what's today today's the uh
well it's trade today's trade datee the
14th so you at some point you going to
have to be trading the the June contract
last trading day is June 19th settlement
is
19th so I'd be expecting it to uh switch
over over pretty
soon um that's why you got to keep the
keep the charts open but right now it's
the volume is still in the
June but it's one of those things you
just got to
watch so I know when I you know back in
the old days you know really would
be the role would be you know on the
12th and 13th the first two days of the
week
preceding that you should be out of it
um you that's the way I've always traded
it but anyway um
um where am I here uh really quick just
look at one other
Market if I can find it
here talk about japen really
quick I could find my
chart now the interesting thing you know
there's some interesting things in the
Japanese Yen
today um you're just sort of going back
to around the
7:00 well I say seven but um you know
after the after the numbers came out so
you had this you know this is kind of
similar to what you had in the euro
currency early you had
your in this case you had a Divergence
with a ratio then Delta scalper the next
bar the the eurocurrency you just had
the Delta scalper but then you run into
this bar was some supportive volume here
you got point of control right at the
bottom you had a ratio bounds
low and you the market popped up here it
went
higher so you know you had some very
bearish signs here you got a nice
bullish sign here telling you hey um
this Market has got some support you
know so if you're short you better think
of covering it and I'm not saying get
long but at least covering it you know
there's something stopping this move
here and we do go higher
you get the Delta scalper here right on
this High you got a Divergence no ratio
up here you got a Delta scalper again
you know this Delta scalper signal
failed came right back and then next bar
sorry three bars later you got Delta
scalper again you got a
Divergence and the ratio of the next bar
so you know just the Delta scalper by
itself you're not convinced you know
then next bar here you got a ratio you
got the uh Divergence so you know it's
giving you some signs that you this
Market can sell off and you know the
other thing you know this yellow one is
is not something I talk about a lot is
this volle's transition and again it's
very similar to the Delta scalper but
it's a little bit different actually but
it's really telling me when I when
there's a
potential um change you know from Supply
to demand or demand to supply and it's
just it's culminating up here you know
right around this high and you know does
market sell off yeah it sells off a
little bit and but mostly goes sideways
before hitting a new
high you know at this high right around
this just off this High you got stack
selum balance does it come off again a
little bit nothing
spectacular
um got Delta scalper but it's on a green
bar here and here you know that's not
where I'm looking to take
it then you know 9:15 you get up here
right on this High you got Delta scalper
you got stack salum balance you got a
Divergence you don't have a ratio you
don't have a ratio on the nextar but you
also got it's hard to see on here but
you've got this um yellow down arrow
which is the U transition again um
giving you a sell so you got a lot of
selling signals up here and the market
does sell off a bit um then just sort of
go start going sideways I really
expected this Market to be a bit
sideways action in the morning um it
moved pretty nicely but again I was
expecting more sideways action in the
morning um you that then again you know
9 you know 1:00 here is where you know
things just went berserk with the fomc
but anyway um this presentation is
getting quite long here I'll I'll tidy
it up for now um anyway thanks for
watching this I hope I made some sense I
hope you got something to value out of
it you know sometimes I I hear myself
talking and I wonder what the hell I'm
talking about but um but anyway you know
if you want to learn more about
orderflows visit my website order
flows.com or the Delta scalper which
we're probably going to you know when I
get my programmer approval we'll
probably hardcode it into the uh nt8
version and so it's not going to be
available pretty soon anymore but anyway
um again thanks for watching this and
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
thanks
bye-bye